it's called fight or flight as as  evolutionary those people have to live  like that do you have your whole life at  you you're 18 now said no understand  with us here the children's home you  know what that means  leave the secret Java soon yeah I'd like  to get a loan  I don't have one in town and I can't  wait you live all alone now you play  things kind of close to the chest don't  you  what does that mean things are secretive  what do you think the outcome of all  this will be for the person who did all  the take is one little word which suits  me to knock things down I don't like you  we don't have  [Music]  I hope Asians have what happened they on  me  [Music]  you  you